thank you to Harry's and expressvpn
for sponsoring more on them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation she's
a super freak super freak she's super freaking
yes Andrew no I was more excited that you did it
then cuz the movie's freaky it is freaky yes and
I'm not a little [__] I'll get a Chlor bomb
Oh Jee je no that really got me that was not a
fake reaction I promise you guys I how could that
have been fake I mean you just I literally got as
but you just look like a little [__] thank you
how long have you been waiting to tell everybody
that you're not a little bab I am you can
let me know in the comments I am it's all
good that's a good segue leave a comment like
subscribe tell Andrew he's uh a big what's the
opposite of being a little [__] a big little
[__] no he's a big boy there you go he's a big
male cat let him know that you're excited that
we're watching freaky also thank you to prepper
for editing down this video for always making
us look good if you are the sexiest of Rejects
and go over to patreon where you can watch along
and sync up with your own copy that's where John
and Greg cover several shows exclusively with
highlights and watch alongs over there I know
literally nothing about this movie you know one
thing Vince vonson it okay that's the EXT of what
we know I don't even know what genre we're
getting into apparently came out during the
pandemic and I paid zero attention now I'm going
to pay attention my eyes are open for freaky let's
go oh the Red Sun is this a DC spin-off I
didn't know communism Great Balls of Fire
you didn't know somebody could say so much
about an intro did you not till just now Roxy
Beverly Hills Productions sorry Blum housee I'm
just kidding I know that would irk you I didn't
know Blum House worked on this huh whoa Wednesday
the 11 you feel it shaky I know what Friday is
going to be he moves through this town unseen like
a ghost and he kills a will every year my birthday
is on the 13th the butcher killed some kids like
in the '90s and then 20 years ago he disappeared
the rest is just local folkore yeah where's my
Purge pillow Purge every during homecoming week
to warn Blissfield teenagers of the dangers of
underage debauchery what would this year's story
be that is not cool that's like Purge
Purge Purge I smell like cheap beer
now I like that she said I smell like
cheap beer she didn't just say I smell
like beer it's smell like cheap beer
Zing whoever bought this is so poor
time to get freaky freaky you did it I did it what
is all this [__] Jenny's dad's an
art collector that's pretty cool yeah
your face says that it's cool it looks
like he's going to vomit that's pretty
cool wow is there some spiritual significance to
this knife nah just a regular dular knife there's
no way to open this thing are you going to help
me or not uh not with that attitude my God this
so teenage angsty are you going to help me or
not whoa did you see the glow there of the knife
yeah ah people who collect
masks are always some kind
of wonderful now that's what I'm talking about
o o that was a wild
shot
malet I'm not going to say it Purge Purge
Purge big cat nice one Sandra you made me
drop it also why did he struggle to read that
so hard I just dropped glass yesterday too got
a nice nice cut from it this looks so what'
you drop Dam it's not fun picking up glass
it's the little shards that get you I love that
the camera keeps dropping to his level as we go
down a POV shot from something that's watching him
every time we pop up I'm like what's there yeah
whoa Adam's Apple
strong wow wow we're 5 minutes into the movie
atude he might be okay that was an intense
first kill usually first kills like they kind
of ease Us in this was like no we're not aing
around agroon knocking won't make me move any
faster he almost looked like Jason from I I
have to get a better look at him it was really
quick I know it's not Jason but I just kind of
look like him now this is just going to be her
friend we're fine they're just setting us up
oh oh oh oh hey jeez oh my God that's an
interesting transition this movie comes hard
and fast I understood where you went with that
one but yes wait what about me you're taking so
did it's vagina not an all night drive-thru could
be both you know that's really inconsiderate yeah
cuz guys are always so considerate maybe
a handy you have to PE after you have
whoa those are very creative kills
are we doing that thing where he
doesn't walk [Music] fast doesn't
oh why would she go into the house
woo
just the absolute dumbest move run away
from the house he's clearly one of those
Killers who can't move faster than that
from the back of his head I would assume
that's Vince Von I oh yeah the back of your
head is ridiculous but if it is Vince Von we
got to remove the mask quick because you
know that his agent must have negotiated
that he can't be in a mask on right
there's a hidden trap door somewhere in
there oh there really was or not
multiple Coke closets all right
where's that dagger I saw it light up
earlier something's going to happen with
that H neat trick okay but maybe stay there like
what are you doing oh he's going to come behind
her somehow why would you come out you knew you
were safe in there this is bad it's got to be such
a mix of emotions going from the pleasur bles
of sex to the horrors of being chased down by
a killer I was worried she was going to get a UTI
because she didn't pee afterwards but I had bigger
bigger F we know the issue of that happening cuz
we experienced it all the time with reactions no
idiot ah like why would she just go running when
she the car like didn't you remember
he was still in the house like yeah
okay I'm so sorry but it's silly cuz it's been so
hard did you see the car at
the end of the driveway no
I did nice ju to position well if she does I'm
going it reminds me of when the parents found Drew
Barrymore at the beginning in Scream one that's
reminding you of that yeah she's just hung up like
that but that was on a tree is it the Beckers and
and how how quickly they killed her and killed
everybody but I didn't recognize any of those
actors at the beginning and none of them were
Katherine Newton so I was like okay we're all dead
right we're getting so close to Friday the 13th
do you have a date for homecoming tomorrow I um
I'm not I'm not going she has a date with
me we're going to see Ricket at the anus
theater did you have to call it the anus seems
a little weird to miss out on a seminal High
School experience to go see [__] regional
theater you know it's just underage drinking
our night is still ending in tragedy that
would piss me the F off if I ask open the
jar but if I'm trying don't take it from
me she opens the jar for her she berates
her oh mom's
drinking wonder why she's such a loving older
daughter yeah but the older daughter has to
be like this because her how many times has her
mom fallen off the wagon yeah I get it do you a
little bit yes you and I both with living moms we
do understand I have to make a DPC reference every
single stream can't get through one without rise
up now you're going to miss the homecoming dance
to go watch some hag and green face hanging from
a wire it's just a stupid dance why do you want to
go anyway I have to shoot it for your but I know
her like personally no oh the girl in the middle
I feel like she's some CW Show or something it's
been a year you can't keep living your life for
someone else you've got to start doing things for
you yeah it's just it's not that easy my dad was
her whole world you don't want to hurt your mom's
feelings it's why I love you I don't want you to
wake up one morning and realize your whole life
passed you by cuz you were busy being everything
to everyone but you it's important situations like
this having a good support system nah overrated
yeah all right he needs to get the first
kill that was the most realistic moment
of the whole movie though that that be
happening in school yeah it does but he
needs the next kill I mean not first
love your dress thanks where you get
it I've had it a long time I think I saw it
at discount banan and I had to did your mom
used her employee discount wow there's a
lot of very nice people in this film yeah
I wonder if there's that mean girl thing that
still goes on in high schools I'm sure there is
like that teenagers can be cruel Roxy but with
delicate detail to the window framing that was
a great awesome shot kill the call us their
home Alan Rock oh I'm in a movie with him oh
really yeah when Cameron was in Egypt land be
on the lookout for crust my presentation is
isn't scheduled till next week this isn't debate
class what you said the 16th it's the 12th we
know that we know it's the 12th Miss Kessler
is holding up the class and once again miss
Kessler is unprepared D something to add Booker
once again miss Kessler's dad died a year ago be
nice is she an Instagram meme or oh wow those
moments are always so wild when you get the
Amber Alert things yeah jinny was one of my
best friends why [__] please jinny hated
ryler after she started that rumor about Jenny
getting a carrot stuck in her P don't say that
word [Applause] whatever Strode Halloween
reference Lori Strode oh good one that was a
good catch okay reference King let's go only
Beaver no would touch I mean you brown back
her face she sort of doable God there are so
many in this movie I also don't get it she's
obviously pretty so it's super weird uh yeah
usually very beautiful girls like that are
not ridiculed to this extent not say it brown bag
her face she's doable like what she's late again
you sure you don't want to ride she's the main
character we have to be empathetic towards her
I am because she's a good actress there's a psycho
roaming free no I'm good there's plenty of people
around and she'll be here any minute I'm good
just go a cute that was really cute can we try
it oh how do you think we did we did [Music]
fine yes great work team it's not a probably
a good idea to be alone what do you mean there's
a killer on the loose of course it's fine to be
alone when four teenagers just got killed I think
your mother is with a bottle okay that was a good
guess wow when you're drinking you're not living
I know but can she not press the Uber button maybe
I know she doesn't have any money maybe damn it h
yeah I guess she's a teenager probably doesn't but
man chisel hi she's passed out on the couch again
can you come get you got to be kidding me right
now okay but it's Katherine Newton so she's got
to live for at least another hour unless they pull
the psycho thing right I'd haven't seen that movie
but I know what happens at the beginning Psycho
Killer coming she comes she'll be coming around
the mountain when she comes everybody now she'll
be coming around the mountain she'll
be slowed down around them oh no we didn't
even finish it oh my God why please don't
be the butcher please like what do you mean
please don't be the butcher what do you think
he is could just be someone who's trying to
scare her my sister's going to be here any
second she's a cop please don't be the Killer
is his hysterical please don't be the butcher
please don't be the butcher is he does he have
the knife in his hand that he got no but cuz
he was using a bunch of different weapons I
know this is the one cuz we saw the shattered
[Music] case oh take your [__] off oh
ah how did she get away from that how
did that bottom fit through that [Music]
a when they come down to your level I'm just
like oh dreary sense of tension she thinks she's
safe but she's obviously not we're about to hear
a boom shaka laka you never know he might be
gone oh no oh no no bad bad bad bad bad Purge
Purge Purge she's going to get pulled from behind
pull from behind pull from behind why run towards
[Music] him it's Child's
Play It's a voodoo magic
trick waa
oh oh it's like what stabbing her stabbed him wait
what get away from her I don't know kind of weird
that she shot up in the air if I saw somebody
stab my sister you better believe I'm shooting
them yeah I mean I get she was trying to scare
him away but still like stab your sister shoot
him uh
people and he's freaky super freaky so the
supernatural element of this is kind of
interesting it's like where are we going with that
where then he got blood cuz that wasn't just her
yeah he stabbed her and then he got blood they're
linked somehow uh let's go reveal what's going
on ah like nightmare in NM Street in the bathtub
I don't worry I won't spoil too much for you I
know you haven't seen those films this is B
to big part oh the sister is ridiculing the
mom yeah I would too sh she would have picked her
up this would not have happened then we wouldn't
have a movie yeah oh yes cover your face that
will help I don't think I'd ever close my eyes
again
oh my God is this going to be Freaky
Friday where they body swap ah could see
that the clock please be Freaky Friday
please body it's funny when we typed in
freaky uh on the to purchase the film it
said Freaky Friday was right below it is
this Freaky Friday oh my God that is the
funniest premise I've ever seen in my life
is that what it is body swapped with a kill
oh my God yeah I think that's what it is oh
my God oh my God okay yeah that's what it is
hysterical oh God to go from slasher horror
film into this that's a interesting blend of
genres yeah because we were only how's your
shoulder 30 minutes in I was like what is this I
wasn't really up far off when I was making that
joke about this being like child's play with
Voodoo that's what it is it's body swapping
that's really good acting you could tell she's
not herself I'm going to give you a minute and uh
I made french toast with your favorite caramelize
bananas ooh I cannot get over the premise of this
movie and that they just called it freaky what
a fun homage and just incredible in general this
is amazing did they say how the dad passed or
no just a year ago accident I think they said
I don't know hope it's not revealed that it was
Vince Von it's going to be annoying if it's that
it's not something else so I don't want them
linked in some other [Music] way come yeah
would be an interesting Discovery for a man oh
God this is going to be so crazy for her and his
body what a decrepit and interesting
place the second act of this movie
is about to be so weird where am I
that's why the cast Vin's F hello it's
the mannerisms I'm looking forward
to pin head that was a pin head reference
Hellraiser this is so cool these
references like this is where
he's been living apparent
laugh amazing amazing I was
wondering why it was Vince
vaugh Jesus oh my God he's definitely got the
Katherine Newton mannerisms down you were just
hallucinating hey you got any jelly beans I'm
sorry do I have Jolly beans you know ice cubes
uh crunchy Munch some drugs man oh my God no
I I don't have any drugs what do I look like
like when you're seeing me right now you know
do I look like a girl girl very petite blonde
it's like if you give me some jelly beans you
might you you you got get drugs you're high
right now oh no I don't have the drugs
come on man give me someone that's good
stuff I want to feel like a teenage girl I
want to feel like a girl come on come back
back I'll suck you all of it all of it unreal
that's worth the admission of jelly beans wow
I was thinking we were just getting another
slasher movie and I was like all right this
is pretty good got you some fresh pineapple
you know how much you love it good juicy one
too dude she's scaring the crap out of me
crispy like you like it me too got to be
crispy oh oh my word okay all right I guess
you are hungry yes Katherine Newton probably
like to the director we got to do this
a bunch of takes I'm hungry today how's
Mellie well I think she's a little bit in
shock but she's going to be be okay she's
going to need years of therapy uh she got
a kill her in her body now they just think
that she's like not well because of what
happened yesterday I thought you were still
sleeping you stopped me from killing your
sister or she said a word not yet honey I
think you should go and get some more rest you're
not thinking of going to school are you school
I mean I know your friends must be worried
about you but friends I'm really enjoying her
performance I think this is such a funny concept
such depth who directed this who wrote this good
on you cuz I had no idea this is where we were
going until literally 2 minutes before we went
there I love how he runs in
this but imagine being a car hitting
a person and being mad at the person
oh oh my God I'm so sorry are
you okay it's you it's him it's
him I'm obsessed with this movie this is
so [Music] fun I would imagine too when
they're not filming their scenes they
have the other actor there to make sure
they're nailing the mannerisms if they're
available or maybe they just spent like
lunch together or something you know yeah
oh my god oh I doubt those girls are gonna
mess with her anymore they're gonna find
out what a perfect song selection right
now s whatever will be will be oh I can see
what oh I feel bad for Alan Ruck or actually
I don't I am having too much fun I'm surprised
she owned this coat maybe she took it from her
sister or mom like why did did he put on red
lipstick he's seen it before in other women
now he doesn't hi have to hide behind a mask
are you okay ow smile for [Music] insta Millie
you're Bliss Fields victim we love you can you
not such an annoying girl off and that police
sketch of course that guy's a killer that gross
bloated sweaty face and brown teeth ooh that take
me uh where some place private something else
happened last night didn't it you can totally
tell me I'm like the most trustworthy person you
think she's dead or no there's a good possibility
of that oh uh hello you dumb broad oh hello oh
hello you're so dead Mama wait are you I mean
it's fine if you are honestly Millie I'm missing
AP Bio I didn't come here to clam jam with you
clam jam I have to use that so I'm going to go
and when I get back you're either spilling the
tea or I'm out freak freak she didn't come
to clam jam oh my God vegetarian she's a
Kuchar oh she is dead your angel of Fate
awaits she is d e a d dead is that the
shower running yes she's about to be bleeding
in the shower oh Vince Von in the oh that's
not what I thought was happening no it did
not either oh my God the butcher's here he
we need to go you need to hide is that in
the cryo are you sure this is safe no oh my
god oh no ah they have a cryo thing in their
school that's crazy must be a private school
oh my God damn she's going to be frozen on him
oh yeah oh my god well it technically is him
just in another body how are they going to body
switch back she's got to stab him or something
oh damn I mean what was that 5 minutes well I
guess that was pretty damn cold so I can see it oh
smash Jesus good commercial for Apple but the
phone survived right that's the most grounded
part but it's like how would he's such like a
how would he know what cryo
did hey how are you old now
lick it lick it
yes that's when you know it's meant to be H
God damn it Millie so sick of your constant
need for attention if only you would spend
a little less time flirting and a little
more time learning you might actually
make something out of yourself that's
your response to seeing her lick blood off a
kid's finger interesting need for attention
I'm just worried about her don't freak out
guys F listen it's not what you think come
on that hurts so much you're black I'm gay we
are so dead stop running I'm not going to hurt
you it's me it's Millie sick how does he know
our name stop running please the away from us
will you live listen to me for a second say
something to prove who you're who you are
guys don't don't really Josh guys stop will you
stop Josh start talking say how you know it's
them ow okay everyone's tired we've done
lots of hitting it's time to talk almost
feel like he broke her back let me two
say something that only they would know
words H Blissfield our Battle Cry that
reminds me of big remember in big when
he would explain to his friend Shimmy
Shimmy Ro what's your favorite movie I
tell people it's Eternal Sunshine but
it's Pitch Perfect too favorite snack
Triple Berry Crushers oh my God love those
who's your biggest crush Booker hooker Shake
[__] choose rule oh my God wait a minute how
what I need a friend right now and it's like
you guys are smashing the [__] out of me like
weird old looking dagger but when he stabbed me
we both got hurt standing in ping is kind of rad
when he stabbed me he instantly got a wound too
but in the exact same spot the left shoulder and
then late last night I kept hearing the dagger's
name like this smoke weed but don't be such idiot
about it this is like three gallons of pee this
guy's platter is huge is everything huge Joshua
well you know this is the boy room right that's
yes that's it that's the dagger it's an Evidence
locker room dagger used in ritual sacrifice do
I wipe there's writing on it I can't read
it aren't you in Spanish 3 and your point
you should be able to read Spanish nobody pays
attention in that class dude Spanish to English
text what does it say you know what she's saying
a little vatro so after after 45 hours if they
don't turn back then they're stuck like
this if the sacrifice is not successful
The Souls of the two persons are swapped and
the change becomes permanent after 24 hours
2 that's very child I said 45 24 sorry oh
bente Quadro 24 hours I love how this movie
is very homage to so many other horror films
it's it's adorable so gross my fart smell I
didn't see what that say one in the stink
Millie Kessler is a gobbler oh my God are
you serious I'm not a gobler hurry up loser
I got to take a dump and there other stalls
I'm sorry sir I I didn't mean to interrupt
I I was I was looking for for someone else
I how's that feel oh the kid who's scared oh
yeah St your pants mess with Milly kler or any
other kid again I swear he better be his pants
Roxy boom did you just yourself it's disgusting
such a movie Trope yeah that's why I call that
I'm going to be stuck in this body forever yep
that's in like N9 hours it's doable where's adola
he at the police station the evidence Locker we
better get going over there now it's good we got
Stakes now he's here somewhere he's wearing my
body and he's wearing my face he's like a wolf
and sheep's clothing and if we don't capture him
first God knows how many people he's going to kill
I know but you should be wearing a mask right now
cuz everyone knows what you look like change your
clothes at least haircut miss kley good bye Al
Ruck you got some nerve stepping back in this
classroom oh this is going to be creative yeah
put on those goggles so it doesn't spur all over
you here's my presentation you're
part of it prediction time Roxy
how's she going to oh never mind oh
we know that she's got the goggles
so blood splatter oh my God not off
oh my God this is going to be [Music]
disgusting she's not that [Applause] strong
[Music]
yes oh yeah but he's Justified right now
I mean yeah just tried to kill him she's
gonna stab him right now of course it's right
next to her that's what you in the ear with me
missing
oh oh you were close
yeah jeez it's like pulsing out like
a heartbeat [Music] a a oh I wanted
the splatter to be on the goggles
I want a goggle blood splatter all
right that's got to be the kill of
the film top kill of the film I mean
Jesus whoa what am I wearing stop right there help
help me R please help me that's why
you should have wear a mask so she's
smart of
[Music] [Applause]
course suspect spotted in a [__] Heap the cops
are like why are the two kids taking him they're
going to be looking for us n could you move up a
little more we need to get you a disguise Mill you
can't be walking around in those clothes with that
face everyone knows who you are good plan Nyla
could you just do just a little teeny teeny teeny
teeny just a little bit more this is me every time
I'm in the back seat like I can't extend my
legs are you tall I mean not like super tall
or anything EXC headwest corner of what are you
kidding me [__] it's the police it's my sister
come
on good parking job no time to park straight half
to park crooked really hide in here
quick do not come out until we get
[Music] you oh I'm so sorry oh is that his mom
or her mom yeah remember works at the discount
store oh okay everybody needs a second opinion how
is the f because we have lots of sizes just shut
up and drink some chardonay I bought my husband a
pink polo one year for Christmas and he about died
Pink So Macho but guess what it looked great
on him oh I bet he loved it I bet it was his
favorite shirt oh I'm so sorry I'm sorry I didn't
mean to share all that with you I just you're just
here trying to buy a polo for God's sake no no
no no no no no it's okay this must be fun for
you right now you okay yeah I lost my dad I'm so
sorry you must miss him so much I do well this is
Dad's stuff my oldest she shut down she retreated
into work and my other daughter she's so quiet now
maybe she just needs some some space I guess I do
smother her except when I'm supposed to pick her
up yeah and I'm too drunk to get there she'll be
graduating high school and running off to college
and then I'll be left here she loves you you're
so easy to talk to yeah you're great you're just
your voice it's so comforting and she going to ask
him out I've had such a good time talking to you
we hardly know each other I know I I haven't even
seen you yet but I think we have a connection and
you do have a connection I'd like to know if maybe
you would like to grab a coffee with me sometime
oh God no a married man mom have you talked to
Milly today no I hav't okay call her and make sure
she's okay was just cited again go let's go come
on to you oh my god what the hell is that quick
put it on your scary Aaron Rogers now yeah that's
like quite a disguise Aaron Rogers is already
scary say Vince Carter I can't breathe it's all we
had time to grab your sister's on our ass let's go
oh my God I can't see [__] how did killers do
this Nyla Drive oh wait did they say Aaron roders
yes oh I thought it said Vince car for some reason
no want a party we should throw one homecoming the
butcher okay sure and where are we going to pull
that off with lens's curfew the old M no one would
look there oh is that where he lives who knew a
little Mill kesser could be such a Crafty Beaver
your touch makes this D than sandpaper monkey I
can't wait to kill [Laughter] you oh my God oh
my God might be the best line in the movie This
T your touch makes this drier thaner you monkey
I can't wait to kill you or effing kill you okay
I'll go check the back you need that knife though
do you think Vince Von's under that mask you mean
or they have just a stunt actor yeah I literally
can't understand you I think that's Vince survive
you go that way there's probably times where it's
not Vince Von and then there's times where it
is I hope that Vince Von saves him right now
because I like him too and I want him and Millie
to have a first dance at prom which I think might
happen don't be a little [__] what about
a big what was what was it big cat big male
cat we hate this place I don't know if the
friends are going to Sur we'll see who do you
think's going to survive the whole movie or right
now the whole Mo or I guess right now yeah I do
think the friends are going to survive how about
him yeah cuz I think that they've set it up that
that's her Crush so and we're going to prom yeah
but a lot of times the crush doesn't survive in in
these horror films yeah but I think the other dude
is more apt to die I think Vince is going to save
her make sure you're okay G to cut
the neck or go for the neck no he's
safeer [Music] oh [__] that's your face you
just hit don't let him get away he'll call the
coops oh wow it's fod is just so such a towering
presence I he whacked the [__] out of him or
her he's still out I I feel like kathern hudon
got way much tougher brunt of damage it's it's
like his soul in her so yeah true true true this
is going to sound really strange Booker Booker
look at me he's crazy okay Booker can you look
at me please please Booker please can you look at
me just for a second oh my God so last night our
Consciousness or our spirit whatever you want to
call it it traded places she's telling the truth
so he stabbed me with the DOA she's telling the
truth yeah I have like less than 6 hours to swap
back or I'm going to be stuck in his body forever
you're all going to jail for this you too Booker
unless you help me Boog up [__] booger this is
clearly not me have you ever seen me dress like
that I mean I kind of like a a lot of what he's
doing with it but it's the point is that you've
never seen me dress like that right do you like
that it doesn't [Laughter] matter no I need
to go right now you're not going to stop me
I'm going to freak out okay I'm not yours not
lost in you not lost although I long to be oh
my God oh my God lost as a snowflake in the sea
you love me this is romantic this is incredible
leave me deaf and blind swept milie oh I am in
love with this movie oh it's the concept of it
it's brilliant we're going to have to figure out
how to steal it and get it back here that's like
40 minutes round trip there's plenty of time right
time is not our friend right now where's the party
is that the Old Mill that's why I woke up in this
body he's luring in there that's a trap then we
better to get moving what about her pronouns
Christ what about him prouns oh my God it is
about your soul that's hysterical oh yeah no I
don't think it's a good idea to leave him here
alone no he's right someone needs to stay behind
and keep an eye on him just in case me it's your
house definitely going to die this time I would
not want to be left alone with Katherine Newton
SL Vince Von you guys stay here honk the horn
twice if you see anything okay what's your plan
don't worry about it I got this how do you think
she's going to get the dagger back flasher kidding
he kidnapped us he made us drive him I escaped
but he followed me here he's here outside behind
the station okay just just stay here okay hide
under my desk one cop in the entire station she
got a keys her keys and it's a small town I felt
oddly empowered being in this body Invincible or
kind of badass oh my God oh my God it's like
there's these heartwarming moments throughout
that it's touching yeah in a slasher horror
film it's interesting blend of genres also a
romcom and I will stand by that oh no I agree
it's a blend of all [Applause] [Music] hello
oh no [Music] Josh oh crap you're home early
my last leg got canceled honey why is Milling
tied to my dining chair good luck explaining this
we're role playing role playing yes role playing
like a game sort of she doesn't look like she's
enjoying herself oh she is oh um that that that's
the point she's she's supposed to act upset right
Millie she's method never breaks character naughty
girl I'm a little confused isn't
role playing a game is it m it's
a matter of perspective I'm Bye Mom I
I didn't want to you until I was ready
but I'm straight oh my God I knew he was
going to say that amazing Joshua you are
many things but straight isn't one of
them now do me a favor and untie her
should have said I'm by that would have
been more selling can't explain right now
but I cannot let him go him no Mom Mom Mom
listen to me he's the Blissfield butcher
God Joshua Michael oh crap no and the KN
is right there yeah she's going to die
run go go go go go go watch out the knife through
the [Music] door it's like Child's Play H should
have listened to your boy it's like we knew there
had to be more kills so his mom had to come home
because I don't think the friend's going to die
so yeah that knife through the door reminded me
Child's Play so you said did you ever see that
one or no is that Chucky yeah maybe first one
so about that poem Oh My Gosh please don't
bring that up that was a total mistake that
was a mistake it's so well you accidentally rode
it and you were just going by my locker and you
tripped and it fell in exactly I thought it was
beautiful the poem probably like 100 times this
actor is probably on Cloud9 right now yeah never
did he think he was going to do this scene with
vin and he's awesome oh he's great I really like
this actor a lot no you didn't Millie I've liked
you since day one oh my God I'm going to I
I how weird is it that I kind of feel like
kissing you right oh my God please oh my god
do it do it I'm so excited right now this is
you'd be kissing a mass murderer with yellow teeth
you're still mly to me oh my God oh my God oh my
God maybe we should wait for when my hand's
not bigger than your whole face it's it's
whenever you want I was not expecting that
I was hoping they would do that that was so
great Millie stay out of this I'm just
trying to help I don't need your help
okay just help help back up shark oh friend
damn start walking towards the cell come on
so hard to explain this to people it's not
a very believable thing start saying facts
about about her start saying what you know
our mom's a drunk our dad died a year ago
well that I mean that's public knowledge in
a small town yeah but just start just start
talking I'm so sorry I really thought your
hamster could swim and I'm so sorry that Regal
died but this is all going to make sense to you
later on I really thought your H I thought your
hamster could swim so you think you're this hot
[__] now huh you I've never made anyone's dry
you make M dry every second you speak oh you
are so gone I don't see him surviving at all
no obviously not and we don't care we want him
dead this is way too dangerous there is no way
we're not helping you Mel we're in this
together 13 minutes left Jesus here come
here come here Us in set of timer time to stab
this [__] it is so laid out perfectly timing
wise structure-wise this is like a perfect
script I am blown away by this movie right
now look like we got a little private party
going here huh are you good at math M cuz
the way I see it you have three holes and
oh my goodness my God kill them all they
were not afraid to go all out in the scripts
no and we're rooting for her now so hard uh
yeah oh she's going to break it cut him
open oh ah
[Music] oh it makes me so queasy with the
necky what are you doing
stop it's so smart because we want we're rooting
for the butcher right now I'm sorry I'm sorry
please oh right in the nut sack oh you are not
going to be able to use that again Millie oh
yeah I uh I saw her really where uh this way are
they going to kiss what is he on drugs and I feel
like they're going to kiss oh why I don't know
did you get sexual attention I'm not going to
I don't say that he might be closeted and he
hiding it oh Phil I don't have time for this
we're oh you caught Vibes I did
not you tell anybody I'll kill
[Music] you I Know What You Did Last Summer
yes get out of here what are you doing
go I like this Arc for Millie though like you
know going from this Dam Zone distress to the
hero Brave heroin I want my body back come
and get it come and get [Music] it [Music]
[Applause] oh drop the
knif [__] this is such an interesting
reverse oh my God he's so slow [Music]
yeah catch
hold what time is it do it now do it
now only one way to find out just do it where's
the Bell what the Bell it didn't hold
Pro tip always set your watch 5 minutes
ahead hold him down no [Music]
no yeah but doesn't the transfer happen
at midnight it's another 5 minutes right
whatever I don't even care okay yeah but they got
to get him I was going to say who's your favorite
athlete uhoh oh at least the cops are there
no one I hate Sports freeze shoot that mother
[Music] yeah perfect timing I love Vince Von's
performance in this film too he's so good like
he was scary as hell and then when he was as
Mill he was like oh I love him hey sorry to
interrupt time to land that plane girl yeah lost
the shoulder honestly the best pain I've ever felt
the voice change again what are you going to tell
the cops a version of the truth I guess let's just
hope nobody ever gets her hands on that thing
I was going to say you should take possession
of that are we ready to try that again I don't
know let's see oh my God I love him and I love
her so cute I am like obsessy
in love with them oh no what's
going on is that his his body he's
not dead oh no how imp pathetic oh
this SE the Carnage sequel bait well
they said the thing about the knife
too ah oh he took it off yeah he's
still alive and he knows where they
live please don't end the way I think it might
what are you think is going to happen I don't
know I'm just it's a horror movie It's just
sometimes it ends in a bad way there's no way
may be ambiguous but you think he's going to kill
her answer the question no I hope not no we're
going to see that her and her body is still Fierce
now sh you left the door open again oh did he stab
sh with the knife you left the door open again
is weird for a cop's sister like is she always
leaving the door open it's a small town I mean but
if there is a butcher on the Lo open not unlocked
open
ah what with gunshots what's the matter
meling she'll be fine that what you wanted
right she's going to prove she's tough
got your body back weren't you shot like
freeze what little girl shouldn't play with
guys whoa
whoa oh [__]
not the TV Millie's going to save the
day cuz strong I think I think you're
right yeah come on Millie you've
been fleshed out you've had your
Ark I understand why you feel so weak
you feel so meager kick him in the BS
I learned something when I was in
your body too what's that ah yes
take whoa I don't care how tough you are getting
kicked in the balls is not easy to keep going on
through I feel like where are the gunshot wounds
I don't see any he has a lot of black t-shirts
through back on over I am peace I am a what I
am a piece a piece what was that a reference to
I don't know I would say a badass Michael
Kennedy and Christopher Landon unreal job
unreal cool the the post credits are
even cool what isn't cool about this
movie Lori Rose you crushed it you DP this is like
I mean is this one of the greatest movies ever it
was amazing I loved it big thanks to expressvpn
for sponsoring this video a real game changer
I've been using for years that's right years
so whenever they want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about expressvpn
for online privacy and security but there's more
to it than that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum showing down my
internet and contacting me due to a suspecting
hacking attempt and funny enough I realized I
hadn't actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences having faced
a serious hacking issue on YouTube a couple years
ago that made expressvpn my go-to for both
security and freedom I mean it and yes what
you've heard is true believe me this channel
knows you can use expressvpn to watch movies
and shows on Netflix that are not available
in your country this means accessing a vast
rate of content of over a 100 countries like
a global cinema at your fingertips it's super
easy open Express VPN switch locations refresh
the browser and there you have it whether it's
kramas on South Korean Netflix Hulu BBC I player
YouTube or more expressvpn has you covered and
it's incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's versatile too
working on not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere any screen
protect and elevate your internet experience so
if you want to get access to hundreds of new shows
use my link expressvpn.com Rejects and you can get
an extra 3 months of expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com reject so head to expressvpn.com
rejects to learn more thank you again thrilled
to be partnering with a brand I've been using
for nearly 2 years now and that's Harry's Razors
I'm generally more drawn to anything that goes
against the norm and Harry's does just that in
The Grooming World they saw the high prices in
the industry and decided to blaze their own trail
with quality and affordability I keep a beer but
whenever you see these cheeks in the neck clean
and that's the work of Harry's right there keeps
my wife happy and Harry's makes it effortless
they're Precision Blades that cut smoothly with
less drag making every shave satisfying and yes
it's versatile for other areas too you know what
I mean so as a Harry's devot I can vouch for their
value you can experience unparalleled comfort and
quality in your grooming routine or exceptional
craftsmanship meets affordability making a smart
choice for a top- notot shave without breaking the
bank their kits and value packs for shaving are
unbeatable but Harry's is not just about shaving
again they offer top quality thoughtfully designed
grooming products including shampoo conditioner
and amazing body wash without the premium price
quality affordability that's a thesis of this
now these I actually pulled right from my own
bathroom I regular L use their five blade razor
with a nice weighted handle and their foaming
shave gel man this that oh it is a game changer I
just like the feel of it now I have to commit to
keeping this in my hand the whole time cuz I'm
not going to go to the bathroom in the middle
of shooting this the handles they feel perfectly
balanced and the razor Sleek design is a classy
addition to my bathroom and the quality of the
shave unparalleled got to reiterate ke part of
my weekly grooming ritual cuz their entire
range of products fits seamlessly into my
routine definitely no re-shoot here their German
engineer blades are durable and refill plans are
economical rarely use the word economical but
I'm using it now plus their commitment to high
customer satisfaction and no risk trial makes
Harry's a no-brainer this Jael really does feel
good let me say once more choosing Harry's means
quality and affordability by grabbing your $13
trial set for just $3 at harry's.com reex you're
not only getting a great deal but you're also
supporting this channel that's harry's.com reex
for your $3 trial set stay sharp and embrace the
extraordinary with Harry till next time reject
Nation till next time we did listen to it very
loud yes we did that's why I became a big cat at
times at some points I couldn't even hear you oh
yeah I couldn't either um by the way if you are
listening to us on Apple or Spotify if you don't
mind giving us a rating we'd really appreciate it
uh yeah no I mean I didn't know what to something
else too something else I don't remember what Greg
said make sure oh trivia oh yes yes yes here let's
that's well I I figur at some point we would do
that you remembered you remembered to uh pull up
wait I'm curious how I know that girl and Alan
Rock so cool oh here we'll we'll look her up too
we're going to look up some trivia for you guys
at Nyla right act BL Nyla was it Nyla oh she was
in Ghostbusters the new one is that how I knew
her that's right she was lucky in Ghostbusters
Celeste o Conor oh yeah but I feel like I saw
her in a TV show once no I didn't a Wetlands no
she just started in 2017 maybe I saw her in a
car how I knew yeah yeah I saw that too I just
for some reason I I kept picturing a CW Show or
something yeah I knew she looked familiar but it
was clearly from uh Ghostbusters afterlife uh here
let's look up some fun facts on trivia before we
get into our review because I know Roxy and I
got a lot to say the original name of the film
was Freaky Friday the 13th that's but freaky
is amazing Freaky Friday the 13th I would have
known what they were doing and with just freaky I
didn't put the pieces together until we got there
Katherine Newton was the first choice for Millie
but she originally declined however after speaking
with Jason Blum about the project she eventually
changed her mind y Jason Blum called her direct
and was like listen babes this is going to be sick
I got to imagine to reading this script like what
an amazing opportunity it be hard to read though I
mean you wouldn't know like what the tone of it is
right that's true I just got to be like depthwise
like this is a fun role or roles to play she was
so great that I can't imagine it being someone
else and clearly Jason Blum couldn't either he
was just like no no it's got to be kathern Newton
so Vince vom was already signed on and kather
Newton was like n uh it doesn't say who signed on
first but it does say the bulk of the movie takes
place on Friday the 13th which we know the film
was released on Friday November 13th 2020 damn it
was a Scorpio meta at the football game Booker's
last name of Strode is seen on The Jersey this
is a reference to slasher icon Lorie stro Jam
Lee Curtis of the Halloween series saw that in
addition Blum House previously made Halloween in
2018 into a Trilogy this we know yep Vince vongh
told the Stunt Driver to actually hit him with
the car when he was crossing the street early
on in the film The Director said Von said he
could take the hit and he did oh my God damn
I mean he's built like a train so I don't do
that yeah I'm sure the insurance compan like
yeah go for it um director co-writer Christopher
Landon cited Fright Night the blob scream scream
to urban legend Cherry Falls and Jennifer's Body
as Inspirations for this film I can see that the
Jennifer's Body stuff cuz I watched that for this
channel also it tonally totally because of that
horror comedy thing that that like thin balance
and also the sexiness of it yeah totally yeah
this was so good yeah I haven't this movie was so
good oh I loved it I haven't seen Jennifer's Body
but obviously I know what happens she gets like
possessed or something in that right and then
she like totally changes so I could totally see
the inspiration for that I mean there was so much
love and homage to so many horror films in this
film I from nightmare in Elm Street in the bath
to scream with being found Austin Witherspoon you
think that's Rees Witherspoon something probably
who knows kather Newton played Rees Witherspoon's
daughter in big little eyes oh maybe the Pitch
Perfect 2 poster in Millie's room is actually the
poster from the first Pitch Perfect film film but
for some reason has the text of Pitch Perfect 2
why do you think I don't know but I never would
have noticed that yeah that's bizarre um let's
find another one there's so many interesting
ones on here um what do you want IMDb yeah Vince
faon also played a serial killer as I mentioned as
Norman Bates in the remake of psycho and as Lester
long in clay pigeons so he's not unfamiliar with
playing these type of roles it was that transition
though right I love how he's able to be fear but
then him being able to embody not just like being
a young girl but being Katherine Newton as a young
girl specifically like when he would throw his
hands up I mean they must have spent a lot of time
together learning each other's mannerisms yeah
well I think also too you probably said like even
during like lunch breaks and stuff like that they
were probably like just going over with each other
cuz I mean I you know kind of like mentioned face
off I really feel like John travol and Nicholas
Cage they nailed the mannerisms like that's what
sold me on that movie was like thinking like this
character is actually that character I mean you
got to get the mannerisms I wonder if for this
they filmed all of the scenes in their own bodies
first so that they could observe each other like
the end scenes and beginning scenes and then they
went into all the middle chunk so that they could
kind of like see and play off of each other's
that's a good point I I mean I would imagine
that would be probably the way I would do it it
depends on money obviously like set stuff but that
like a smaller budget film even though it it yeah
Vince Von's fall during the auditorium Chase was
accidental and not scripted V slipped on the fake
plant that was knocked over and lost his balance
but he continued on through the scene okay in the
opening sequence when the butcher kills his final
victim with the spike on the wall he tilts his
head the same way Michael Myers did in Halloween
after stabbing the victim on the wall see homages
to all the other ones the poem that Millie placed
in Booker's Locker which he recites to him is
I am not yours by Sarah Teasdale fun stuff fun
stuff let me see that was well we can be done with
the the trivia portion of this now this one's for
you Greg we did it we did it yes way to go sorry I
have a ring on I probably just all good I I barely
felt it um I barely feel anything ex what was
the deal with the line at the end I am a piece
I would have liked I'm a badass but you guys let
us know in the comments piece I I don't know must
we must have missed some line earlier um but I I
thought it was just so brilliant uh like blend as
we mentioned during the reaction just blending all
the genres like slash horror uh romcom and then
also the supernatural element I just like but it
was executed in such a meticulous and fun way and
scary way it just like when you blend all these
genres like just telling me about it I would have
been like I don't know if that's going to work but
then actually watching it the way it was executed
in the film and uh the way it was portrayed I was
like I loved every second was actually fun and
scary at the same time and it so it was great and
I love the arc too Millie went through throughout
the film like again she's you know obviously she
has this loss that she has to deal with with her
father it's gotten uh obviously it's affected
her family kind of a broken household and you
know she's obviously it's it affects her at school
people are extremely mean to her and she kind of
uh you know kind of a weak character in terms of
just like you know from taking things on mentally
and physically too obviously she was attacked by
the butcher not really much you can do with him
anyways in terms of physically battling him but I
just love this transition she goes throughout the
film she's a really fully fledged uh fleshed
out character and I love by the end like it's
actually fully earned like I bought that she you
know killed him at the end like that was fully
believable after everything she had gone through
and all the you know physical and mental turmoil
she had gone throughout the film I I loved her
transition towards that badass at the end I agree
and I think to what you're speaking about this
movie made some very smart choices number one they
could have ended it right when Vince vongh when
they switch back bodies and he gets shot but they
didn't because they wanted to show the full Arc of
her that she is changed in her own body it's not
that she could defeat him because she was in his
body it's because it's inside her the whole time
and so I thought that was really brilliant along
with a lot of other choices they made uh just
to not have to for the first 25 minutes for the
First Act of this movie to have us think okay we
are coming out the gate strong this is a slasher
film even though we know some Supernatural there's
this lore with this knife we're seeing like okay
what could this be as we had uh the almost like
Aztec set up and everything going on you're like
what is this and then you realize freaky freaky
Friday just so so brilliant and also I I think
that when we when we are talking about a lot of
movies on this channel you we'll talk about the
performances we'll talk about the dialogue we'll
talk about the DP uh or the cinematography which
in this was unbelievable the music but often times
it's not the premise that makes the movie and in
this movie it's the premise I love the premise
like this is the best elevator pitch ever it is
Freaky Friday but you're swapping bodies with a
serial killer yes that's the whole movie and then
they just they knew they had it they were like oh
that premise is Bomb now let's play around like
crazy so once they they really believed in their
premise and they were like we're not going to
shy away from this this is wild we're going to
make it so that she has to in his body convince
our friends convince the guy she likes they have
that conversation in the backseat like they did
they played with us in every way possible and
into this premise that they created I just think
this movie is a perfect script it's perfect for
people who are looking to write a film like it
hits every Mark in terms of its act structure
and how much fun it's having like this is one of
the best movies that I've seen reacting on this
channel it was perfect it was great and it's a
shame too it came out during Co because I before
yesterday I never even heard of it I didn't know
I've never heard it until today we sitting yeah
Greg texted me like have you ever seen freaky I
was like I've never even heard of it um and then
I I the only thing I saw mdv was cuz I just wanted
to see who the cast was I didn't look up the the
premise uh cuz Greg said dude please don't look
up the premise I want you to naturally see what
happens uh so I just saw that Vince vaugh was in
it um because I just wanted to see which actors
were in the film um but then like being naturally
surprised like like you said in the First Act of
one uh the first part of the act one like we just
see it's a slasher film is what I thought we were
in for and then to be naturally surprised like oh
my God no there's going to be a blend of genres
here and I you said they just really stuck the
landing and I just was they didn't do the thing
you were worried about what was I worried about
that he was going have killed her dad oh thank
yeah and again when you were talking about just
nailing like down tropes and all that I mean there
were a couple things that were tropy but they were
self-aware and kind of met which I appreciated uh
but yes I'm so glad and honestly it would have
made sense if they would have said he was the
reason I mean obviously there's a me a morat of
reasons that the father could have passed away
in terms of you know human beings um passing away
but obviously this butcher clearly is terrorizing
this town so that could have been you know I mean
I would have accepted it I just didn't want them
to be linked that way so I'm really glad that they
steered away from that because that is a a horror
tropy thing that I'm glad that they stayed away
from yeah me too especially because I think that
it's it is not to get into my whole issue with
Man of Steel but it the point of a lot of these
things is like there's things in life you cannot
fix you cannot change and then there are things
that you can fight for and you be can become the
best version of yourself the most badass version
of yourself and you can fix and solve and like
whatever happened to her dad I didn't want the
point of this to be that she could have saved him
you know like they could have found this guy she
could have I think he just had an accident but
the point of this with him is that when he first
was coming for her there was nothing she could do
until she became the most best version of herself
and and then she realized she was strong enough
and it was inside her just really really great
storytelling I can't also describe enough how I
think that the movie was made by kathern Newton
and Vince Von oh yeah nailing this yeah their
performan again it's the mannerisms and before
I continue on that I really think I understand
now how her father passed away he was probably
caught up in a tornado she had a chance to
super speed in she didn't she chose to hide
her vulnerability I can't hear you anyway no I
cannot yes but uh getting back to this uh choking
aside getting back to this uh and she just lets
him die I know right hey it's it's I understand
not a heart attack you're there I I how is that
Superman I I I understand what Snider was going
for even though I disagree with it but let's get
back to this um we'll talk about this off camera
um but it's the mannerisms in their performance
and I just love to like in the beginning to and
also to the depth of like before I get to Vince
Von like Katherine Newton's performance like at
the beginning as I was mentioning earlier seeing
her like just so D like damil and distress type
of like when you saw her running from again you
don't expect her to put up a fight against Von's
like three times her size um but just like again
taking the mental abuse from all the the people
and like like the way she's coming off uh you know
and also like having to deal with her father and
then like when she's scary as hell with Vince
Von's soul in her body and then like when you
see her as a badass like it's just such an amazing
depth of range in her performance and vice versa
when you get to Vince Fawn he is scary as hell
in the first like 15 20 minutes and then the yes
how about this I love the little [__] in the
but like he's nailing it's it's the mannerisms
when he's nailing like he's really convincing me
like I mean that he is Catherine Newton in and not
an obnoxious like I'm a girl yeah no it it could
have like could have been to your point it really
could have come off as extremely obnoxious and and
yeah cuz there's so many ways to to mess that up
and he didn't he really nailed his performance as
Katherine n it you know something else smart that
they that I felt like oh wow this could have gone
so wrong and you guys did this perfectly they only
killed people we wanted dead that's true except
for the very beginning obviously we don't know
those kids but they did seem kind of obnoxious
right like smelling cheap beer we didn't really
know them to but they didn't like I love that they
didn't kill the two best friends um I thought that
the two best friends were awesome supporting
characters they didn't kill the mom they didn't
kill the sister they didn't kill kather Newton's
character they didn't kill the crush they killed
I thought the the crush was going to die I knew
he wasn't because we needed the real kiss they
killed Allen Rock's character they killed the the
[__] that tried to straight up sexually assault
oh my God that was they uh they only killed they
killed the mean girl in school in the crowd uh
by the way let us know in the comments section I
don't care but do do other than private schools
do they really have cry freezers in I mean that
was the least believable thing not not the not
the uh the voodoo Supernatural stuff that was
the least believable thing to me but I I went
to public school but I grew up in like a a nice
neighborhood we didn't we don't have stuff I went
to an extremely extremely rich public school I
know if there is I know it's it was free but a
lot of you should have seen you should have seen
the parking lot mercedesbenz Galore same thing
look at us I know right well isn't it nice yes
right yeah uh but anyways yeah um but no cryo
machine yeah no cryo I mean I don't even think
cryo was a thing when I was in high school anyways
uh another thing I appreciate in this uh film I
loved uh the camaraderie and the teamwork between
the three friends they were so good together I
want you to know I drove a Honda Civic I drove a
Trailblazer so just I I wanted to be I I I wasn't
the super rich kid I saw all of them but I oh no I
drove all them like have it was my brother's car
and he let me take it I I appreciate I liked my
my Trailblazer it was cool too and G gas was uh
you know not too bad priced at that point so was
six yeah right um but I what do you think of the
the three friends together cuz I loved the their
chemistry together the interactions there were so
much fun and then also too was really I like that
to me it it felt very reminiscent to Big when
he was trying to convince I believe Billy was
his young friend was Tom hanks's friend's name
uh when he was trying to convince him like I'm
I'm really J Shazam I was thinking of oh yeah good
point this is all DC Talk I don't know if his name
was Billy but I'm with you what I thought of the
friends is that I thought that they were awesome
that the girl was so good the the um Catherine's
best friend yes what was did you say her name was
I think Nyla N I think she was so good that I was
convinced that I knew her from a show somewhere
because I was like well she on the flash like what
do I know her from and then it was Ghostbusters
but she was so good and so endearing immediately
that I thought that I knew her and then the other
guy I had never seen before but I was like he is
funny and quick um I even liked like when getting
his mom in the scene and seeing how they're
interacting and him being like and I I love
that moment cuz usually it's like they come out
and they're like I'm gay and then he came out
he said stra she hone hear a lot of things that's
not one of them um he was going to say I'm by just
kind of normalizing so I thought that was great
too but I love those friends and then I really
love the significant other or the the crush it was
great that we like added him on to the dynamic and
then he came in all the right moments um and I
just thought he was so sweet and charismatic and
that you believed he had chemistry with Vince
vaugh in the back seene in the back with vin he
like you said he must have been on cloud n when
he was filming that scene he's like I just did a
a romance scene with Vince vaugh what like and the
context of the scene too it's just so great uh so
so great this movie could not have been better
I mean is I mean pick for me do you have that
last line I don't I didn't get it I must missed
something oh the the pie that's my only nitpick
I'm like what was that I should have understood
um yeah I guess that um I don't know just so
many people were pieces of shits in this I guess
but I mean that's I guess that's real life you
know people some people can be pieces of shits um
but also too that makes you know that makes them
fodder to to get uh you know annihilated I guess
so um yeah we're rooting for the kills so smart
yeah exactly um I don't know not really too much I
again I I loved it I love the the blend of genres
all this I thought it was very fun while also at
the same time you know it made me be a big cat at
the same point too I was I got scared at moment
Purge Purge Purge I got I got scared I got scared
plenty um so and I I just I love the performance
as the premise I thought heartwarming stuff yeah
was yeah like even in the when when Vince vongh uh
was as Cather in the dressing room I thought that
was so sweet and endearing it was beautiful I mean
th this movie spoonfed me exactly what I wanted
couldn't be happier with it going to recommend
this to everybody yeah like this is one of those
hidden gems where you're like have you seem freaky
you got to go see freaky yes all right well if you
have seen freaky you just did because you watch
with us then like comment subscribe tell us what a
big group of cats we are me especially I know and
that's all reject see you next time [Music] later